so on what date do I tell her dad than I
love him today I'm gonna be getting
relationship advice from teenagers how
old are you I'm 15 cool that's cool I
used to be 15 not or one awkward at all
how old are you guys
we're 14 I'm having some trouble with my
girlfriend's dad and I'm just wondering
how do I get him to like me well in a
modern sense you could find out some of
his interests without asking beforehand
okay the good old internet stock is a
good way to go sure he's not on the
Internet I'm in the Navy some of the
challenges are that we're in the middle
of the ocean so there's not a lot of
internet so it's very difficult to
communicate with your spouse how much
longer you in the Navy for 13 years
suicide your life away I know you guys
said you haven't been a relationship
before but if you were to be in a
relationship are you comfortable with
your significant other can go hang out
with his ex no like I guess it depends
on how the relationship ended you know
like because it would all be different
and it's a conversation you really need
to talk through teenagers say be honest
adults you guys lied too much all right
cut it out how'd you get a boyfriend who
looks um like a cougar [ __ ] oh another
ship boy or you could just have a
swimmer who just like swims like this
the boat there's any swimmers out there
but it soon would be 39 you get out of
the Navy that's not like too old to get
married I guess what I'm wondering is
when do I call him dad you should
probably ask your girlfriend when that
would be appropriate and comfortable for
everybody involved
do I call him dad or should I call him
pop-pop doctor dad mr. dad that sounds
pretty formal sir dad call em dad dad
kind of like make them like think that
I'm his baby again bringing back to the
good old days the dead dad that actually
sounds like a wonderful and perfect idea
great we're making great progress here
if you meet a person that you
really like and you're putting your
career first above the relationship if
the person you guys will make it work if
you guys are meant to work it maybe it
isn't the right person if you put your
career before baby
like what emojis can I send him I would
go straight in with all of the colored
hearts even the black heart sure I got a
bad boy edge yeah you have a very rich
boyfriend yeah I do
I do need a very rich boyfriend rich
boyfriend I'd be like what's up dad I'm
the L painting emoji for shadow I know
something we might do down the line I
mean the debt and we'll have a nice
dinner and I'll ask him if I can call
him daddy and present him with the new
balance sheet I'll give him those
grass-stained New Balance sneakers that
he's always wanted thank you so much for
the advice it was really good advice I
know yeah well submit our invoice later
I believe that relationships can be
successful if you operate by these four
things communication honesty
understanding and respect which
boyfriend's call her
[Music]